three bulletproof strategies for
achieving your goals in 2023 in this
episode of the podcast we're going to be
talking about why most people fail to
achieve their YouTube goals how to spark
Unstoppable motivation in 2023 and some
practical tips for winning on YouTube
this year but I want to start with a
story of two people who started 2023 and
they both set a goal however one failed
and one succeeded so the first person
they set a goal and their goal was to
lose 20 pounds now the second person
they also set a goal and their goal was
to walk 20 minutes every single day who
do you think succeeded
with their desired end result well you
can guess see the first person they set
a result goal they wanted to lose 20
pounds but the problem was they didn't
create a plan or Define the actions
necessary for actually achieving the
goal see the second person they actually
didn't even do their goal perfectly they
ended up averaging only five days a week
of walking 20 minutes a day because of
course you get sick you go on vacation
in fact some days you wake up you don't
even feel like doing it but what
happened as a result of just focusing on
the actions walking 20 minutes a day
averaging five days a week for the
entire year by the end of the the year
that person lost 20 pounds increased
their energy boosted their confidence
and created momentum so they could
tackle new and bigger goals one of the
reasons people fail to achieve their
goal goals on YouTube is because they
just focus on the results but they don't
actually Define the actions nor do they
really create a bulletproof plan and so
I want to share three areas that I
personally go through when goal setting
and I also want to share some practical
tips for winning on YouTube this year
and the first area is set results goals
it's not bad it's not bad to want to
lose 20 pounds and it's not bad to want
to get 10 000 more subscribers this year
and so it's important to know what are
our targets no goals no growth if we
don't set a Target we don't know what
we're steering towards and so a couple
questions here is what is your desired
subscriber growth number what's your
target there how many views in a year do
you want to get and also what kind of
money do you want to earn from YouTube
at the end of 12 months how much money
do you want to earn and what is that
breakdown per month per week
is there any collabs or interviews that
you want to do this year have you made a
dream 50 list a list of people in like
an Excel or Google Sheets spreadsheet
that you want to consistently reach out
to maybe some of them sound impossible
but you never know until you ask and you
never know until you ask consistently
and so what are some of the results
goals for you secondly though and more
importantly is what are the actions that
it's going to take to reach those goals
how many uploads are you committed to
doing per week and one of the ways you
can power up your chances of success is
to make your goals non-negotiable see if
your goals are optional then you're
going to be casual about it but if you
can make them non-negotiable you're like
come hell or high water I am uploading a
video every Tuesday even if I have to
stay up all night the night before to
get it done that's the kind of mindset
that it takes to create Unstoppable
momentum on you YouTube if you're casual
about it if it's just optional then you
ultimately will find that at the end of
the year you may be disappointed because
once again you fell short of your
targets are you going to be uploading
videos shorts are you going to be doing
live streams I want to challenge you to
experiment with different content
formats even if you don't love shorts I
hear a lot of feedback I don't want to
embrace shorts these short vertical
videos are ruining people's attention
spans I just like the old way YouTube
was done friend I understand that change
can be hard but what's waiting for you
on the other side of experimenting with
a new content format one it could be
viral growth and new awareness and new
subscribers to your channel but two for
sure it'll be growth for you challenging
you to be more concise in your
communication to learn how to storytell
at a different level to learn a new
content format like YouTube shorts and
to potentially develop a skin skill set
that I believe is critical in a 2023
world and that is vertical video content
creation that can be distributed across
multiple platforms not just YouTube so
are you going to block some time to take
new actions so that you can get results
you've never gotten before what are some
of the routines or habits that you need
to establish so that Weekly you are
moving towards your goals skill
development I mean listening to this
podcast is a great way for you to
continue to level up your skills level
up your mindset and so blocking time for
leadership development personal
development YouTube skill development
where you're also taking action while
you're also very busy I know you got a
lot in your plate so it's going to take
a new level of discipline if you want
the next level of domination on YouTube
in 2023 but the third area
I actually think is the key to making
this all work this is how you spark
Unstoppable motivation in 2023 and the
third area is to raise necessity and
Define your reasons let me explain
usually the reason we don't actually
fulfill on our goals is because we don't
do the stuff and the reason we don't do
this stuff is because typically the
stuff is hard it's one thing to say I
want to lose 20 pounds it's another
thing to say I'm going to go to the gym
three times a week for an hour but it's
a whole nother thing to actually go to
the gym I mean that's what that's been
my challenge it's like you know be
easier than going to the gym and lifting
weights not going to the gym and lifting
weights how about I just stay home and
watch more YouTube on my Smart TV with
my son and so ultimately what is our
challenge here it's the resistance it's
us having procrastination it's us
putting off what we should do do today
until tomorrow so how do we solve this
friend I believe the way you solve this
is by getting stronger reasons and
tapping into your true motivation that
moves you emotionally I've learned that
reasons come first results come second
and here's how you can start to
power up your motivation
how much money do you want to earn on
YouTube this year
you already defined that in number one
but here's how we go emotional
how will that change your life
can we marinate on that
if you were to earn five thousand
dollars a month on YouTube sixty
thousand dollars a year how would your
life be different I want you to feel
that I want you to even visualize and
imagine that is that mean that you could
be part-time at a job you don't love
does that mean that you could
ultimately completely go all in on
YouTube does that mean that you could
put money away in retirement to build
generational wealth or to save up for
that home upgrade so you have enough
space for you and the family how will it
change your life
another question is who will be impacted
by your content
like who's waiting for you to share your
entertainment to share your education
listen I know it can be easy to get
discouraged and say Sean my small
YouTube channel doesn't matter Sean
there's so much competition who's going
to care about me but friend I need you
to know that your message matters and
there's people that are waiting for you
think about this if you get a silver
play button you get a hundred thousand
subscribers you've made a lot of impact
it takes a lot of work a lot of people
will have watched your content it's a
lot of comments it's a lot of people
clicking like it's a few trolls it's a
lot that has happened between now and
then but imagine if after all of that
happened
if you just didn't take action and you
just stayed safe and never stepped out
you know I just turned 39 and over the
holiday season I I'm embarrassed to
admit that I lived a lot of my life
without ever watching the film It's a
Wonderful Life
and my wife I don't know why she didn't
know that but she heard that and she was
she was aghast she was like what are you
talking about you've never seen It's a
Wonderful Life who even are you do you
even have worth as a human you know how
my wife talks to me and I was
um I'm like okay I'll do it you know
it's kind of long it's like two and a
half hours and I started it out I kind
of liked it at the start it lost me in
the middle but by the end I was in a
puddle of tears and if you haven't seen
the movie
it's ultimately about a man who had a
lot of ups and downs in his life and
eventually reached a point where he was
very discouraged and even suicidal and
an angel from heaven was sent to
actually encourage him and tell him to
keep going and his methodology for
helping him realize that was actually to
show him what life would have been like
had he never existed
all of those little touch points his
relationships with people in the city in
the community and when he showed him
what his life would have been like his
his wife his kids that didn't exist
because he never did and if you've seen
the movie you you know the emotion you
know all the feels that comes with it if
you haven't seen I think you can imagine
I want you to really ask the question
whose life will be impacted by your
content and whose life will miss out
on the message and the encouragement and
the education that you have to deliver
if you just stay comfortable
and you stay in fear and you stay in
hesitation
you got to raise necessity and this is
actually a secret of high performers one
of the largest studies ever done of high
performance leaders discovered that what
they do is they raise necessity what
does that mean it means that when they
set a goal when they think about their
YouTube channel they don't think about
it as just ah just a hobby you know
whether I do it or not it doesn't matter
just kind of like a cool thing I'm doing
for the people who perform at the
highest levels they raise necessity that
people are dependent on me I am on a
mission I need to put my content in the
world they raise necessity about who's
the enemy that they're fighting who are
they helping what is the purpose of
their YouTube channel what's the vision
of the channel what's the or their
business right or any category but in
our case like this is why at think media
we have a mission we have a vision we
are Purpose Driven why we continually
talk about those things I wrote a uh 10
reasons why our mission matters at think
media and I've taught on it in slack and
I've in zoom and I've posted it in slack
and we've talked about it five or six
times and Brian shares pieces of it on
our social media I should probably do a
podcast on it 10 reasons why
think Media Matters in our mission
matters see it's still hard for me to
sometimes want to get out of bed get
motivated and do hard things and fight
the hard battles of building a channel
building a business of doing it when you
don't feel like it of doing it when you
want to quit friend you got to raise
necessity and you got to Define your
reasons so so why do you want to succeed
on YouTube this year I want to encourage
you to journal about this and write some
of these things down and think about
some of these things
and what will it feel like when you
reach your goals on YouTube at the end
of the year like imagine January 2024 I
want you to think about the emotions not
just the dollars not just maybe the
accolades but the feeling of
significance the feeling of
accomplishment let's say the dollars and
the accolades don't come
how are you going to feel when you set
out to do something I'm doing a video a
week and two shorts a week and at the
end of the year you go I did it you know
how much confidence comes from follow
through
you know your confidence grows when you
actually make a promise to yourself and
you follow it follow through on it with
yourself
you know that every time you kind of say
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna go to the
gym tomorrow and you don't how do you
feel after you don't feel great you feel
like you let yourself down see a lot of
us don't feel like we're leaders but all
of us are some of us have teams to lead
and people to lead
but no matter what we all have to lead
ourselves and we develop more character
when we set goals and we set action
goals and we actually follow through on
them maybe you'll double your subscriber
goal that you set or maybe you'll only
get 40 there but I assure you you are
going to experience new levels of
momentum of confidence and if
you follow through and so how is that
going to feel
what is it going to feel like to
visualize the cover image on your
YouTube channel and the Avatar and the
playlist you can organize and the series
that you've created and the body of work
you've put out into the world your
portfolio of videos your video library
what is that going to feel like you know
I've learned that ultimately those who
achieve their goals on YouTube that have
Unstoppable momentum again don't just
set results goals but they also set the
action goals and they also build a plan
and you know if you actually want more
help building your plan we do have our
tube 1K challenge coming up soon if
you've never been a part of this for
five days you can join me in the think
media team
sharing the latest tips and strategies
for growing on YouTube but I think more
than that it is an environment where you
don't just set goals you don't just
learn tactics and strategies but you
also will be around a community that
will help spark motivation and you will
raise necessity and create momentum so
that you can absolutely crush it on
YouTube this year you know it is free
and we only do it a couple times a year
the link is in the show notes or you
could go to tube 1kchallenge.com if you
want to register but the last thing as
we think about this point number three
why do you want to succeed on YouTube I
just want to briefly share one of my
reasons and why I want to succeed you
know if you haven't heard my story I got
into all of this back in 2003 I started
shooting video for my local church 2007
we started a YouTube channel for that
church which is crazy that was two years
after YouTube started and I uh was
behind the camera I was doing video
production there was actually 15 minute
time limits when on uploads back then
you couldn't do custom thumbnails the
YouTube Partner program didn't exist and
by 2009 I finally posted my first video
if you've ever been on one of our free
classes or some other places you know
it's this horrible video where I'm like
I don't want to be energetic I don't
want to be entertaining I had no idea
what I was doing I didn't have a plan by
the way that's why we are obsessed with
helping people develop strategy and
create a winning plan on YouTube uh
because I that's what I wish I had back
when I was starting but a lot of people
don't know the reason I started YouTube
was because I was actually in the
hardest season of my life in 2009 my
wife actually almost died she got super
sick in 2007 on a mission trip to the
Philippines and then when she came home
she started to throw up 10 to 15 times a
day it was awful and we were super
overwhelmed because we didn't know why
she didn't know what was going on we
were living an hour north of Seattle in
the Arlington Marysville region and
doctors had no idea what was going going
on in fact some doctors were even super
mean and toxic even saying why don't you
just eat why don't you stop being
anorexic but there was something much
deeper going on and eventually in 2009
she lost so much weight that she got
down to 82 pounds it looks like she had
been in a concentration camp she
literally was Skin and Bones and so they
had to do a feeding tube which they
first put in her nose so she could get
her nutrition up a little bit and then
eventually they installed it J Unum
which is where they put it in your side
and they placed it wrong so when the
food started to be distributed the
liquid I remember we were living in a
house in Marysville we came home with
all this medical equipment and all these
boxes of this canned liquid nutrition
and all this stuff and I'm filling up
the machines and the bags and she's
laying down and we turned on the machine
and all of a sudden she goes Sean my
whole body's like it's like burning up
like I I don't know what's wrong I I
feel like I'm in all this pain and I
feel like my whole body's on fire and
what we realized was that they had
placed the tomb tube wrong and it wasn't
going into her stomach the liquid was
filling up her body cavity later on we
discovered that that'll ultimately
suffer suffocate your organs and it can
cause you to die quickly so we turn it
off and threw her in the Honda Civic and
we rushed to a hospital in Everett
Washington where they got her stabilized
in the emergency room and from there
they got an ambulance to take her to
Seattle where they had better machines
and better equipment and I they threw
put her in the ambulance sirens are
blazing it's night time it's dark it's
raining it's Seattle and I'm following
her in the Honda Civic we got there we
got her stabilized they had to cut her
open clean out around her organs so back
around Oliver sew up the incision and I
remember I'm in the hospital room for
six days why she's recovering while
we're going through all of this and I
don't know if you could feel the
emotions you know but this was insane
like it was scary he and I'm afraid I'm
feeling very insecure am I going to lose
my wife I'm also feeling insecure about
a lot of other things because I'm like
what are we gonna do like financially
like I'm sure this is going to be
expensive this is you know medical bills
had already been piling up and we were
already you know on top of this
happening we were already in the midst
of absolute Financial Devastation the
2008 bubble burst in real estate and we
were losing our home that we were living
in house hacking before it was cool we
had a family living with us and two
other roommates all paying rent just so
we could afford the mortgage but as
people started to be dispersed and lose
their jobs they're gone so we're we're
unable to make the payment on that house
we had another rental property that the
tenants lost their job and that was on
an 80 20 arm we're losing that as well
and then on top of all this at this
exact same time our church was actually
falling apart which I was part-time
staff at I was waiting tables at Red
Robin and I was also doing video
production and some senior leaders stole
some money and so that was that went
from 1700 people on Easter down to 200
people it was like just total
Destruction so I am surrounded by just
the most discouraging
overwhelming painful uncertain brutal
season my wife too I mean think about
her situation and and I am like God what
is happening and what are we gonna do
and I share all this with you just so
you can have a little bit of insight
into my reasons reasons come first
results come second because it was
really in that hospital room that I
began to First be a little worried and
anxious but second begin to develop a
fight in my spirit that was man I gotta
figure this out
I gotta fight for my family I got a man
up I gotta I gotta find a way to make
money and when I when I'm writing down
my reasons it wasn't because I want a
Ferrari it wasn't because I want to be
famous I don't need to get on YouTube
because I want more followers those
things are all cool I think even if
that's like a byproduct of something
deeper but I've just learned that again
if you want to spark motivation the root
word of motive the root word of
motivation is motive what's your motive
for wanting to do YouTube and when you
get up every day and you're fighting for
your family and when you get up in every
day and you're just fighting for
survival but you're clear on the vision
like I want something better and I even
have very practical things like I was
like we want to start a family someday
and we didn't know if we a could because
we're going through these challenges but
I thought okay we're dual income my wife
may never be able to work again I gotta
figure out how to make more money or
dual income maybe we'll be able to have
kids but we'll probably need help we'll
probably be able to need uh to hire a
nanny I got to make more money and see I
was Raising necessity not so I could go
buy a watch I was like I want to pay
people to help with the vision and this
was just what I was going through at the
moment these were the pieces I was
adding into my puzzle for building
Unstoppable motivation that pushed me
through the first five six years of not
getting big results on YouTube of doing
it as a side hustle of making just a
little bit of extra money but not going
full time yet it took me about five or
six years while I still worked in
another job I also wanted to be
responsible I worked at a job that had
health care Etc and so what are your
reasons what are the deeper reasons
Family Mission purpose I also think
about things I think you tube needs a
higher level of leaders it needs it
needs influencers that are not obsessed
obsessed with self and greed but that
are mission driven and that are Purpose
Driven so I'm personally on a mission to
hopefully be one of those people but to
inspire others that we need more
positive we need more faith-based we
need more leaders we need more people of
High character and high ethic creating
the best of the best content on YouTube
so I'm tapping deeper into my reasons I
know that this story is going a little
long but I share this because it just
matters so much and I hope to inspire
you friend I think this could be your
year
2023 could be the year you really double
down you take your results to a whole
other level you reach your goals but the
reason you do is because you've raised
necessity when it's not just I hope my
channel grows so I can get a silver play
button but if not no big deal I'm like
my wife's life is on the line it's two
different levels of necessity you know
but I mean I'm like the next generation
is on the line because they're following
influencers of low character of greed of
selfishness of vice and we need to raise
up some men and some women that actually
are standing for something different and
that have got a more powerful message
than 99 of these social media
influencers that are out there it's a
different level of
known you
get your goals you set the actions it's
going to take and he might be like Sean
chill out bro like I literally just want
to have like a hobby gaming channel
that's totally cool but I've just found
that if you want the fire to be
unquenchable
double down on your reasons go a little
bit deeper I want to thank you for being
a part of part of the think media
podcast Community definitely stick with
us because we've got a powerful year
planned and if you haven't registered
check out
tube1kchallenge.com where you can
register I I should probably close the
loop as well because if you haven't
heard the story what's been amazing is
that my wife Sonia is doing very well
through a lot of prayer a lot of fasting
a lot of Medical Treatments some bad
doctors but then eventually some good
ones it's been a wild journey and
actually today we have two boys which
are absolute Miracles and uh you know
I'm not sure what your faith background
is but literally uh you know we are
Christians we're people of faith and we
uh we believe that God moves powerfully
and what was pretty wild was uh a year
before my son was born two different
people said by this time next year God
told me you're gonna have a son I mean I
know that's crazy but it's true like so
I was like the first one and then next
day I was at an event this the second
one and uh and I was like huh could be
something told my wife she laughed at
first and then um she was praying and
felt strongly about that and really it
was a miraculous that we had our first
boy Sean Bradley and now we just have a
three-month-old John Steven and so I
just share that because uh the majority
of the last 13 years have actually been
really hard especially those first five
or six a lot of pain discouragement
challenges challenges in our marriage
marriage counseling wanting to quit
wanting to give up but I've seen the
power
of keep of consistently pushing towards
your goals of consistently applying
pressure towards the dream and the
vision that God has given you and what
can happen over time right some people
most people overestimate what they can
accomplish in a year but underestimate
what they can accomplish intent I know
this podcast is all about this next year
but friend where are you going to be in
the next decade
if you set clear goals if you define the
actions and if you raise necessity and
get clear on your reasons I believe that
you could exceed even your wildest
dreams